Guten Morgen Andre.
Guten Morgen Andre. Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, fühlst du dich eigentlich manchmal beobachtet?
Nur weil du den Linus hinter mich gesetzt hast, der auf mich aufpassen soll.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die einhundertachtzehnte Ausgabe, ich bin's, der Tim und äh Linus ist nicht da, passt aber auf, wie wir schon gehört haben und äh dafür begrüße ich andere, andere Meister, hallo.
Hallihallo.
Ja genau, du bist der Stand in.
Für Linus. Ja. Ich muss ja meinen Score mit Thomas wieder aufholen.
Genau, während Linus jetzt im Urlaub an deine Fingernägel knabbert und sich fragt irgendwie, werden sie diese Sendung verhauen oder nicht? Na ja, äh wer dich nicht kennt, du warst ja hier äh schon öfter äh zu Gast und schreibst für Netzpolitik äh Punkt ORG.
Ganz fleißig, nachdem du jetzt auch deine lange Reise hinter dich gebracht hast, ey, dass ich wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr auf das lange.
Es ist schon wieder länger her als die gedauert hat.
Ja genau, also es es gab ja dann auch kein, kein, kein Mangel an Beschäftigung und äh das Tagesgeschäft ähm hatte ich schon lange wieder eingeholt.
Dazu gehört ja auch, dass du äh sehr fleißig dem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss beiwohnst, so ist denn möglich ist, also im Rahmen der öffentlichen Anhörung und äh im Rahmen der ansonsten zugänglichen Dokumente, da gibt's ja dann
bisweilen immer mal wieder auch was. Aber jetzt war ja gerade mal wieder eine,
Anhörung, die sechste öffentliche Anhörung ähm sechzehnten ähm sechzehnten Sitzung des Ausschusses.
Das findet er dann immer schön im Bundestag statt in einem von diesen.
Sitzungssälen.
Diesen runden diese runden Dinger, ne.
Das sind die öffentlichen äh sind die runden Ausschuss äh Seele. Meistens ist das im Europasaal, ähm den man schön Blick auf die Spree hat über dem Lampenladen, dem Restaurant, im Paul-Löbe-Haus.
Mhm. Wie groß ist da der Andrang?
Ähm von den öffentlichen Besuchern, also die Ausschusssitzungen, wenn sie denn öffentlich äh sind, äh heißt
Da kann jeder der Öffentlichkeit hingehen, man muss sich einfach nur anmelden, vorher eine E-Mail schreiben, dann kann da jeder hin, da brauchen wir noch keinen Presseausweis und so.
Und je nachdem, am Anfang, als der Ausschuss gestartet ist, war das sehr äh voll auf der Tribüne und dann als äh Benny und Drake kamen, war's sehr voll
in den letzten Sitzungen hat sich das so ein bisschen eingependelt. Am Anfang sind diese äh ist äh Besuchertribüne meistens so ein Drittel voll.
Aber je nachdem wie lang das geht und das geht durchaus auch mal bis Mitternacht sitzt man da zum Schluss dann nur noch zu fünft da oder so.
Und wann fing's dann an?
Meistens Mittag um zwölf, aber das wird dann unterbrochen durch diverse Sachen mit, die Abgeordneten müssen ins Plenum vom Bundestag, sondern in der namentlichen Abstimmung,
dann müssen die teilweise untereinander nochmal klären, so welcher Teil das jetzt öffentlich, welche ist jetzt nicht öffentlich und so, das geht manchmal hin und her.
Verstehe. Also das ist jetzt nicht so einmal so zack hinsetzen, Ausschuss fettig aus, sondern ist so ein Prozess.
Hoffentlich äh manchmal ist es tatsächlich so, es geht um zwölf äh also letzte Woche ging's stand um zwölf drauf und es ging dann halb drei los, aber normalerweise ist es so, es geht um zwölf los mit einem öffentlichen Teil und solange wie der öffentliche Teil geht, wird das durchgezogen.
Leider ist äh ja wird das manchmal unterbrochen und das passiert ein bisschen anders. Bisschen Flexibilität mitbringen.
Was gab's denn äh diesmal schönes Neues zu äh hören? Wer wurde denn da vernommen? Waren wieder die Herren und Damen mit den lustigen Namen?
Ja, eigentlich sollten eigentlich sollten Frau K und äh nee, Frau F Punkt und Herr F Punkt com,
Punkt kam's gar nicht mehr, äh nochmal um das aufzulösen. Äh das sind äh BND Mitarbeiterinnen und äh und Mitarbeiter,
Initialen genannt werden, um ihre, ja, Identität zu schützen,
die Initialen sind auch gar nicht von ihrem Reel Namen, sondern von ihrem Name, also es dürfen keine Fotos von denen gemacht werden, äh in der vorletzten Sitzung war das der Leiter der Dienststelle in Bad Aiblingen.
Öffentliche Sitzung war und dann auch noch ein Leiter ins Fachbereich, in dem Kies XX Kieskow eingesetzt wird. Und in der letzten Sitzung letzten Donnerstag war das die Frau Doktor F Punkt,
dass die Datenschutzbeauftragte des Bundesnachrichtendienstes und die hat tatsächlich.
Eigentlich sollte man sich nicht allzu viel von diesem Ausschuss erwarten, weil das ist so wie der Rest der demokratischen Kontrolle von Geheimdiensten. Man kriegt halt das mit, was in den, was irgendwie an die Medien kommt
oder was sie die Geheimdienste einem geben, wie hier, das dürft ihr wirklich erfahren. Wir geben euch das frei. Das ist ja nicht so, dass die ein Recht hätten, dass die juristisch durchsetzen könnten, da reingehen und sich Akten angucken können oder wie das wirklich funktioniert.
Äh umso schöner war es, die Datenschutzbeauftragte da zu haben. Die hat nämlich dann tatsächlich mal aus dem Nähkästchen geplaudert. Sie ist dafür verantwortlich,
dass äh das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz eingehalten wird im Bundesnachrichtendienst nun leider wird sie nicht dafür verantwortlich, dass auch das GC-Gesetz eingehalten wird mit dem.
Dann einige Kompetenzsachen hin und her, so wenn's konkrete Überwachung gibt, da hat damit hat sie nichts zu tun, dafür,
G zehn Gremium da, aber so allgemein, dass das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz eingehalten wird, dafür ist sie da und es gibt dann sone Sachen wie.
Wenn's eine neue Datenbank gibt, dann gibt's da 'nen förmliches Datei Anordnungsverfahren und dann muss sie das prüfen, ob das bestimmte Zugriffsrechte und Löschpflichten äh und Sicherheitsvorkehrungen halt eh die Datenbank genutzt werden darf, stellt sich heraus,
Das haben die Ehe gar nicht immer gesagt. Also nach Snowden äh und dann teilweise erst letztes Jahr im November
irgendwie die Abteilung technische Aufklärung, das ist die Abteilung, die für das ganze Siggid, also so das äh Abschnorscheln, digitaler Kommunikation, äh zuständig ist, kamen auf sie zu und haben gemeint, äh hier, hm, Frau Dokt
der F Punkt, wir müssen ihnen da mal noch zwei Datenbanken nennen, die bisher,
aus Gründen irgendwie runtergefallen sind. Und zwar waren das die Datenbanken äh und Werras.
Und die sind einmal ein äh Inhaltsspeicher,
von Telekommunikation, also E-Mails, Telefonanrufe und so, wo hunderttausende Kommunikationsinhalte sind, hat man hier nicht gesagt.
Warum solltest du sowas auch die Datenschutzbeauftragte wissen.
Das ist bestimmt nur ein bedauerliches Missverständnis äh
und die andere Datenbanken ist so eine Megavorratsdatenspeicherung mit Millionen und Abermillionen Einträgen, äh wo also Meter Verbindungen, Verbindungsdaten, wer, wann, wo, mit wem kommuniziert hat, über E-Mail, Telefon und so weiter und so fort
Ähm das was das Bundesverfassungsgericht abgeschlossen hat, macht natürlich der BND trotzdem weiter. Äh.
Bescheid, dass das macht, zumindest nicht der eigene.
Ja noch nicht mal der Datenschutzbeauftragten Bescheid gesagt.
Mhm.
Genau, das mit den Datenbank war eine lustige, was heißt lustig, so lustig ist das gar nicht, äh aber eine interessante Erkenntnis aus dieser Sitzung.
Das heißt, sie hat quasi jetzt in der im Rahmen der Befragung gesagt, dass sie davon sehr spät erst Kenntnis erhalten hat und hat hier überhaupt erstmalig von diesen Datenbanken berichtet oder wusste man das schon, dass es die gibt?
Es gab von der vier und auch von
äh gab's schon mal in bei Spiegelberichten so eine Seitennote. Da ist der Name mit aufgetaucht
äh aber wofür die stehen, was dadrin gespeichert wird und was der Prozess ist und vor allem, dass sie die Datenschutzbeauftragte darüber nicht informiert haben,
war mir zumindest neu. Ähm.
Verstehe. Hat ja der Ausschuss tatsächlich schon mal was gebracht an der Stelle.
Es gab auch noch weitere interessante News in dem Ding äh in der Sitzung zum anderes Ding ist, äh die der BND betreibt ja diese Satellitenabhörstation in Bad Aibling.
Das ist auch ganz offiziell so, dass äh Kommunikation von Satelliten äh abgehört wird,
dass da auch Daten von Glasfasern und von Frankfurt da Internetknoten ankommen und so, das wollen die nicht so wirklich zugeben und das erfährt man dann auch wieder aus der Süddeutschen, mit dem Namen Alconal
Äh aber offiziell ist das da für Satelliten abhören,
da hat sie gemeint, naja es äh auf deutschem Boden mit deutschen Mitarbeitern äh also ist das eine ziemlich deutsche Angelegenheit, ist ja auch im Auftrag des deutschen äh Nachrichtendienst, also geht da ja auch deutsches Gesetz, BND-Gesetz, ne,
Präsidenten des BND Schindler gesagt und der meint nee,
weil es ja im Himmel dieser Delitten und deswegen,
müssen wir uns nicht an BND-Gesetz halten, weil die Kinder, die wir greifen die Telekommunikation ja da ab.
Außerhalb des offiziellen Luftraums.
Genau, völlig losgelöst von der Erde.
Gott. Oh man.
Genau und dann ging das ein bisschen hin und her. Sie hat gesagt, äh nee und der äh BND-Präsident hat gesagt, doch und äh übrigens, wenn du mir widersprichst, dann habe ich recht.
Und deswegen ist das bis heute die offizielle Rechtsauffassung des BND, dass beim Satelliten abhören in Bad Aiblingen äh das BND-Gesetz nicht gilt.
Was man auch in das größere Bild einordnen kann, denn in der allerersten öffentlichen Sitzung des äh Untersuchungsausschusses hatten wir drei äh,
renommierte äh Verfassungsrechtler da, die gesagt haben, die komplette Auslandsüberwachung von BND ist auch rechtswidrig, weil die da nämlich so tun, als müssten die sich in Afghanistan nicht an deutsche Gesetze halten, müssen sie aber genauso. Die müssen da auch,
selbst wenn sie Afghanen anhören, haben die auch Grundrechte, die sie genauso beachten müssen, schämen sie sich aber auch noch nicht drum. Insofern, dass das BND-Gesetz nicht nur.
Ja, wie ist das der schöne Spruch aus den äh fast alle Menschen sind Ausländer, fast überall.
Und dass man fast überall auf der Welt das deutsche Gesetz bricht ist das eine und jetzt bricht man es aber auch in Deutschland.
Fragt sich jetzt, ob die Satelliten selber auch Grundrechte haben.
Keine Ahnung, es gibt ja natürliche Personen und juristische Personen, keine Ahnung, du bist doch der Weltraum in Satellitenexperte.
Gibt's auch noch so technische Personen oder so, die haben dann keine Grundrechte. Auweia!
Genau, das sind dann so lustige Sachen, die man äh im Ausschuss erfährt.
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage zu dieser Veras Datenbank. Also du hast ja gesagt, das ist so ein bisschen Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also welche Daten äh wurde denn das gesagt? Welche Daten da jetzt tatsächlich drin landen? Also handelt es sich hierbei um Telefonver
Care oder Internetverkehr oder beides.
Ähm ich nehme an, Telefon und also äh Verbindungsinhalte.
Was dann so wirklich Kommunikationsverbindungsinhalte sein dürften, wie Telefonate, Telefongespräche, SMS, E-Mails und so,
Ähm es ist ein bisschen äh steht übrigens für Verkehrsanalysesystem. Ähm,
es ist ein bisschen unklar geblieben, weil die äh die Datenschutzbeauftragte,
BND, die war recht offen und die wollte das dem Ausschuss, sie ist ja auch verpflichtet, vor Eid äh unter Eid äh da auszusagen und wahrheitsgemäß und vollständig auszusagen.
Sie wollte das auch tun, aber da kam dann immer mal 'ne Intervention, erstens hatte sie den Anwalt Johnny Eisenberg
neben sich sitzen, wie die anderen BND-Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter vorher auch und ich nehme an, der wird da auch weiter sitzen
und dann sitzt hinter ihr noch Vertreter der Bundesregierung, namentlich Bundeskanzleramt, Innenministerium, dann sitzen auch irgendwelche Leute mit Militäruniformen und so und aus dieser Reihe kommen dann immer mal so äh hust, hust, das
dürfen sie jetzt aber nicht sagen, weil sonst ist das Staatswohl gefährdet. Äh und die.
Sagen die so Lithry, also.
Die halten die dann ab und unterbrechen die um bestimmte Aussagen zu tun,
Das darf dann, wenn,
nur in öffentlich in nicht öffentlicher Sitzung erfolgen und das ist dann dieser Zirkus mit alle packen ihr Handy in eine Blechdose und das wird auch noch Klassikmusik gespielt und die gehen überhaupt eine ganz
in den Ausschusszahl des Auswärtigen Ausschusses, wo das alles ja also so ein Theater machen die da.
So so mehrere Feridation, äh Käfige äh so ineinander.
Genau. So ein, so ein Zirkus, äh das ging normale Nachrichtendienste hilft aber gegen die NSA wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich.
Abhörpuppe, ja.
Genau. Insofern äh das kann ich jetzt nicht definitiv sagen, was da drin ist. Äh ich kann nur sagen, was sie angedeutet hat äh und da hat sie gemeint Metadaten äh in dem Moment äh.
Protokoll war das so lang zueinander.
Sind Metadaten aus Leitungen und inbe äh sind Kommunikationsinhalte.
Da sind sie wieder, die schönen Meterdaten.
Genau und die Metadaten werden von BND, das war auch eine ganz lustige äh Aussage von ihr, nicht nur äh von einer Zielperson und deren Kontaktpersonen und deren Kontaktpersonen,
sondern auch noch von deren Kontaktperson und deren Kontaktpersonen gespeichert, also bis in die fünfte Ebene.
Das ist ziemlich krass. Das fand ich eine äh sehr relevante Kernaussage von dieser ganzen Anhörung, also die äh BND.
Ich mein, mal ganz abgesehen davon, dass ja ohnehin anlasslos alle abschnuschelt, äh aber dann in der Datenbankspeicher, wenn ein Selektor angeschlagen hat, man quasi entweder eine E-bekannte E-Mail-Adresse, IP-Adresse, ähm äh
Telefonnummer oder so von einem, wie auch immer, Terrorverdächtigen oder überhaupt.
Die Abteilung technische Aufklärung sorgt auf ihre äh auf der Webseite des BNT, stellen sie die Abteilung technische Aufklärung mit, ja wir machen das äh für die Information der Bundesregierung und zum Schutz von unserem Militär. Da steht noch nicht mal Terrorismus, aber,
Der offizielle
Ist ja immer, das geht gegen die Terroristen. Also wenn sie dann einen Verdächtigen haben, wo der Selektor angeschlagen hat, äh dann werden nicht nur dessen Kommunikationspartner und wiederum dessen Kommunikationspartner, sondern das Ganze fünf Ebenentief,
in dieser Datenbank gespeichert und ausgewertet.
Das heißt, man sollte sich nicht nur Sorgen machen, wenn man jemanden kennt, der ein bisschen fishi ist, sondern man muss jemanden, äh es reicht schon, wenn man jemanden kennt, der vielleicht jemanden kennt, der vielleicht jemanden kennt, der vielleicht jemanden kennt, der vielleicht ein bisschen fishi ist.
Genau. Genau so.
Doch jetzt glatt mal drüber nachdenken.
Nee, da brauchst du nicht drüber nachdenken. Äh du kennst mich und damit reicht das.
Danke. Na toll.
Und wir kennen alle Anne Roth und so. Wir sehen ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ich glaube auch.
So eine Verbindungen.
Gefallen bin, ist eh alles vorbei.
Hat die dann auch äh direkt gefragt. Also das ist dann so der Bekannte, der Bekannte, der Bekannte, von einem Mandanten, von einem Anwalt, ne, also so der Arbeitskollege vom Schwager vom Babysitter, vom Anwalt des Mandanten.
Hörer uns kennt ihr ja jetzt auch schon ganz gut. Das war's.
Ja, äh aber ist ja eigentlich nichts Neues. Wir wissen ja, dass wir alle überwacht werden.
Ja, aber jetzt weiß man eigentlich auch immer mehr, also ich finde, was ich überhaupt so in letzter Zeit abgezeichnet habe. Ich meine, die ganze Debatte drehte sich immer so um NSA, NSA, NSE.
Die hört alles ab et cetera und jetzt grade in den letzten Wochen
kamen ja äh verstärkt einfach äh neue Informationen im Hinblick auf, ja wo kriegt sie denn die Information hierher? Na ja, vom BND.
Und ähm mit solchen Datenbank äh Berichterstattung verfestigt sich ja im Prinzip das Bild, das ja eigentlich.
Dieses Feindbild NSA, was sicherlich nicht unberechtigt ist, ja, sich im Prinzip genauso auf die Tätigkeit des BND auch erweitern lässt, oder?
Ja, ich halt's auch äh für extrem ungünstig, dass dieser Ausschuss NSA Untersuchungsausschuss genannt wird. Ich nenne den, ich nenne den immer Geheimdienstausschuss,
Geheimdienstuntersuchungsausschuss und hat angefangen, den einfach BND-Untersuchungsausschuss zu nennen.
Klar William Benny hat auch in der zweiten Anhörung gesagt, der BND ist ein Wurmfortsatz der NSA und die ganzen Stories über enge Kooperationen ähm ja wir haben ja auch Alconal und so gelesen
sind ja bekannt die machen ähnliche Sachen, tauschen sich aus, arbeiten Hand in Hand und das ist Aufgabe nicht nur dieses Ausschusses, sondern auch der Medien zu belegen, was denn da tatsächlich passiert.
Hm. Jetzt gab's ja da noch ähm so einen anderen äh Vorfall im Rahmen dieses BND-Ausschusses, da bist du dann selber auch mal so ein bisschen zum kleinen Medienst da geworden.
Ja, ähm ja, also fast. Äh also wir haben.
Begleitung. Schutzbewohlen.
Äh so am Anfang der Sitzung, ich setze mich wie immer aufm Platz ganz vorhin und da, wo der Strom ist, weil man muss ja über viele Stunden äh mitbloggen und da hält der Akku nicht.
Äh hinter mir noch ein Journalist, neben mir auch noch ein Journalist und dann stelle ich fest, äh dass ich in der dritten Reihe äh hinter mich äh einen einen Polizist setzt, einen.
Beamte oder der Bundestagspolizei, die Bundestagspolizei ist ja eine eigene Polizeibehörde.
Hörte dann Knopf im Ohr und äh einen nur ja halb gut aussehenden Anzug und so eine grüne Karte, die ihn als Polizist äh ausweist und dann habe ich ihn gefragt, Bundestagspolizist, ne? Jap.
Ja, sind sie jetzt für uns hier? Mhm, sieht so aus, ne? Dann habe ich gesagt, echt jetzt und für wen von uns dreien? Wir saßen da in so einer kleinen Gruppe, wenn Journalisten.
Jetzt sage ich nicht und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, sind jetzt wegen mir hier. Na, wenn ich mich umsetze, kommen sie dann mir hinterher. Ja.
Und äh das habe ich dann erstmal war ich ein bisschen geschockt, was soll das.
Also der saß unmittelbar hinter dir oder nochmal so zwei Reihen.
In in zweiter Reihe unmittelbar hinter mir saß ein Journalist von Golem und hinter ihm äh saß der äh Bundestagspolizist. Aber der hat mir dann gesagt, es geht um mich.
Aha, einfach so.
Ja weiß auch nicht so genau warum, dann habe ich das mit in meinen Block ja da mit aus dem Ausschuss äh habe ich das da reingeblockt äh mit,
dem Zusammenhang gerade wenige Stunden davor, also vor der Sitzung hat der Ausschussvorsitzende Sensburg noch die Arbeit der Medien gelobt und die CDU hat gesagt, ja wir brauchen ja keinen Livestream, weil es gibt ja einen Liveblock.
Ähm ja und unsere Berichterstattung wäre exzellent und sowas, ne, setze ich mich da hin, habe einen Kopf hinter mir,
Das getwittert, äh nicht
äh ja auch getwittert und geblockt und dann kommt der Leiter des Ausschusssekretariats zu mir und hat gemeint, ja, Entschuldigung und äh das geht hier gar nicht um sie, sondern irgendwie die sitzen ja immer im Raum, das kennen sie ja äh und da habe ich gesagt, ne, aber der hat mir gesagt, dass es um mich geht.
Und dann meinte er, naja, ihr Name ist halt bekannt. Und da habe ich gedacht, wat? Ja.
Das will man ja wohl hoffen, dass der Name bekannt ist, aber auch der alle anderen Journalisten.
Ja, aber genau, wenn da äh Leinendecker oder Maskulo drin gesessen hätten, die äh die Story gebrochen hätten, äh dann glaube ich kaum, dass der Name ist auch bekannt, dann glaube ich kaum, dass die einen Kopf hinter sich gesetzt äh bekommen.
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau, warum das äh passiert ist. Ähm kann mir nur mein Teil denken, wir haben's ja nun mit Geheimdiensten zu tun. Die haben.
Noch irgendwas mit mit dass dass sie Angst hatten, dass so Flyer verteilst oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist, ich habe vier Begründungen gehört, warum das war. Also mal ganz abgesehen davon war das immerhin sowieso nicht persönlich gegen mich, was ich aber dann von den Aussagen von den beiden äh anders habe, dann die erste Aussage war, dass ich keinen Livestream mache.
Wessen Aussage war das jetzt?
Na, von dem Kopf und von dem Ausschuss Sekretariatsleiter und dann später auch der Bundestagspressestelle.
Aber zum Beispiel meine Webcam am Laptop Network ist ohnehin abgeklebt, schon lange vor, Snowden. Äh Mikro ist da wahrscheinlich drin,
aber das ist eh immer auf müde geschaltet. Die zweite Aussage war dass ich die Ordnung also dass niemand die Ordnung im Saal stört.
Dann war es weil ich irgendwie so 'nen Snowdensticker einstecken hatte die ich immer einstecken habe auch bei allen vorherigen Sitzungen und die Angst hatten, dass ich die runterwerfe und jetzt gestern die neueste Begründung war ähm da war das da man von dem Platz wo ich sah
äh Fotos von den BND Mitarbeitern machen konnte mit dem Smartphone äh und die ja wohl nicht gemacht und an die Öffentlichkeit äh
äh ja veröffentlicht werden dürfen, weil die sonst enttarnt werden und das dann könnte man die nicht mehr öffentlich anhören. Also das war dann aber auch die vierte Begründung, äh dass,
geht so ein bisschen hin und her. Ähm ich werde das nicht auf mich sitzen lassen. Ich werde mich dagegen bähen. Ähm,
Ich nehme das nicht, ich
Also ich kenne das aus anderen Zusammenhängen, das kann manchmal so ein Wink mit dem Zaunfall sein, vor allem nach der Story sind die alle ein bisschen unruhig. Und auch die Abgeordneten, denen wurde ins Gewissen geredet. Äh das liegen ja gar nicht geht, auch wenn man den ganzen Ausschluss in einem Liege äh verdankt. Ähm.
Ich ich werde mich davon nicht einschüchtern lassen, aber viel wichtiger ist, es geht gar nicht um mich,
Ich hoffe auch, dass sich niemand anders davon einschüchtern lässt, die Ausschusssitzungen sind öffentlich, da kann man einfach hingehen, zumindest die Abgeordneten freuen sich auch über Öffentlichkeit.
Genau und mal um das in Relation zu sitzen. Ich hatte jetzt das war so ein bisschen bildhaft. Ich hatte halt einen Kopf hinter mir sitzen. Aber eigentlich das ganze Thema von dem Ausschuss ist ja auch, wir werden permanent alle überwacht.
Also ich finde die Aufregung da, also schön, dass der Karib Biermann das auf Zeit online aufgegriffen hat, aber das eigentliche Ding ist ja, wir werden alle permanent überwacht. Jetzt war's halt nun mal sichtbar.
Ja. Wie wie muss man sich denn überhaupt die Präsenz dieser Bundestagspolizei im Normalfall äh vorstellen? Also sind jetzt wirklich in jeder öffentlichen Anhörung immer Bundestagspolizisten auch anwesend.
Ja, ich glaube, ähm die ja, die die sollen halt tatsächlich die Ordnung im Saal äh wahren. Und wenn da jemand äh von der Bühne rumpöbelt oder manchmal sind.
Das ist auch nachvollziehbar.
Sind auch Glasflaschen verboten, manchmal nicht und so, je nach je nachdem. Ich dachte, meine Matte nicht mit reinnehme, aber dann darf ich mit drinnen eine Matteflasche kaufen.
Aber ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass sie jetzt besonders aufgefallen äh wär's, dass sie jetzt irgendwie besonders viel Flyer verteilst, oder? Also.
Nicht im Bundestag, ne, das,
habt ihr auch am Eingang gezeigt und ich war ja auch das fünfte Mal in diesem Ausschuss und so, das mit den Flyern habe ich noch nie gemacht. Normalerweise sitzen die irgendwo ruhig im Hintergrund äh und langweilen sich oder spielen auf ihrem Smartphone rum oder manchmal versuchen sie auch dem der Sitzung inhaltlich zu folgen.
Du hast das jetzt aber auch wirklich noch nie gesehen, dass die jetzt überhaupt in diesem Pressebereich, ist das ein separater Bereich? Nee, das ist einfach normale Tribüne und die Presse mischt sich quasi mit allen anderen Besuchern. Und ist das überhaupt üblich, dass die.
In dem Bereich überhaupt sind.
Ja, die sind da öfters mal.
Okay. Aber wie bist du denn dann darauf gekommen den anzusprechen? Also was war jetzt.
Der war direkt hinter mir, der war der der war die bisher nicht, der hat mich angestarrt und später nachdem der weg war, so nachdem wir uns beschwert haben, eine Stunde später ist er auch woanders hin. Das heißt er in der Mitte vom Raum und hat sich aber so hingesetzt, dass er die ganze Zeit zu uns rübergeguckt hat und so.
Also wenn ich den Kopf hinter mir habe, das fällt mir schon auf und dann spreche ich den auch an.
Okay. Und was wird da jetzt so, also ich meine, du hast halt Protest auch eingelegt beim Bundestag.
Ja, ich habe mich äh beim Sekretariatsvorsitzenden, äh der hat mir eine Mail geschickt, dass die auf seinen Auftrag tätig waren und äh dass das alles nicht so gemeint war und dass es nicht um mich ging, da habe ich ihm eine lange Mail geschickt
dass ich unter Zeugen seine und die Aussage des Kopfs haben, dass es sehr wohl um mich ging.
Und ich gerne mal gewusst hätte, ob das seine eigene Entscheidung war oder ob da irgendeine andere Behörde im Zuge der Sicherheitsüberprüfung, die man da vorher machen muss, ihnen das gesagt hat, leider noch keine Antwort,
dann irgendwann hab ich 'ne Anruf von der Pressestelle des Bundestags gekriegt die haben sich total entschuldigt denen ist das peinlich den ist die Arbeit der Medien da total wichtig die haben sich auch bedankt für die Berichterstattung
die kamen dann aber auch nur mit den Ausreden, das ging nicht um mich und wird nicht wieder vorkommen so ähnlich,
Abgeordneten sprechen das nochmal an, äh die sagen auch alle, das geht nicht äh aber ja ich bin in Gesprächen mit äh Anwälten,
und vielleicht, das ist noch nicht ganz spruchreif, vielleicht ergibt sich da noch was juristisch dagegen vorzugehen.
Wie gesagt, es geht nicht um mich, das soll auch äh keine Schule machen, da soll jeder äh ohne sich ein Geschichte zu fühlen, äh teilnehmen können.
Äh der Beitrag von Köln Biermann darf Zeit online, der war ja auch relativ klar positioniert, dass äh das hier im Prinzip noch Vorzensur riecht, die halt genauso wenig äh.
Erlaubt ist, wie
Zensur und das in dem Moment, wo halt, ne, ist mal die klassische Situation, Einschüchterung von Berichterstattung, so nach dem Motto, ja, wir haben nicht im Auge, das ist natürlich das, was jetzt hier aus den äh Ritzen quillt bei dieser ganzen Story und das kann äh
nicht schön sein.
Nochmal ganz kurz bei dem äh Ergebnissen aus diesem Untersuchungsausschuss. Wir haben ja schon angesprochen und hier auch äh letzte Woche schon behandelt. Die News um äh Alconal,
Die also im Prinzip,
eine Story ist, dass eben die Daten, die die NSA vom DCX ähm erhalten hat, vom BND erhalten hat, nämlich
wie eben auch schon kurz nochmal angesprochen über den Umweg äh Bad Aibling, also der vom BND betriebenen Abhörstelle
und ähm da gab's jetzt nochmal so einen Leak in Anführungsstrichen, was von einem SPD-Abgeordneten kam namens Christian Fliesek.
Dass die NSA.
Daten zwar erhalten hat, aber das dann selber auf eigene Initiative gestoppt habe. Das war jetzt eine Aussage auf Basis von Dokumenten, die er dort gesehen hat,
und dort hieß es, die Datenfilter des BNDs seien äh zu stark und sie hätten damit in der nichts anfangen können.
Ist jetzt eine windige Story. Einerseits ist halt die Frage, ja, also klingt das jetzt realistisch, dass quasi der BND dann doch äh äh vorgefiltert hat und andererseits,
was davon gehört, wie es diesem Abgeordneten jetzt geht, weil es gibt jetzt wohl auch die Debatte darüber, ob er das halt sagen dürfen.
Genau. Ähm also ist ja,
nochmal zur Erinnerung, die Abschnuschelaktion des BND am DCS und bestimmt auch anderen äh Knotenpunkten und Glasfasern. Äh die Daten gehen von dort nach äh die Zentrale im Pullach,
und dann gibt's bei all diesen ob das jetzt
ähm Satellit oder Glasfaser ist, verschiedene Filterstufen. Das erste ist tatsächlich so eine äh Blacklist, das ist dieser G zehn Filter,
dass Daten von Deutschen, weil der BND ist ja ein Auslandsgeheimdienst und darf theoretisch keine Datendaten deutscher.
Technisch betrachtet. Wir gucken mal, ob da das DE Domain drin ist. Mhm.
Das das ist der große Running Gag, dass wir auch aus einigen Dokumenten so haben. Äh das wird nicht alles sein, äh aber tatsächlich ist da unter anderem dabei, ist eine deutsche IP-Adresse,
Ist das eine E-Mail von der DE Domain äh oder ist das eine Telefonnummer mit einer Plus vier neun und so. Die ist die sind noch komplexer, aber das ist auch Bestandteil davon. Äh und,
danach in einem zweiten Schritt gibt's noch äh so Whitelist mit den Selektoren und Selektoren sind eben verschiedene Identifikationsmerkmale, wie eben
'ne Telefonnummer, 'ne E-Mail-Adresse, 'ne IP-Adresse, 'ne Gerätenummer oder auch 'n
äh eine Browser-ID und so. Es gibt da, es gibt Dutzende, äh die NSA hat bestimmt mehr als dutzende, wahrscheinlich über hundert Selektoren,
die dann aus diesem großen Pool nochmal rausgefiltert werden und,
ähm leider haben sind die Alkoholakten nicht öffentlich, deswegen können wir uns nicht aus den Primärquellen äh informieren.
Aber soweit ist das verstanden habe, stand in dem Bericht der süddeutschen, ähm dass,
die der BND an die NSA
nicht nur die G zehn gefilterten Daten gegeben hat, äh die also der G zehn Filter ist der äh filtert
Deutscher raus und ist so fünfundneunzig Prozent äh genau, ihr hattet das ja letztes Mal ganz lustig, wenn euch jemand fünfundneunzig Prozent Uptime verkauft, dann kann er seinen Laden eigentlich gleich wieder zumachen,
Ähm.
Sondern ähm der, also es ist klar, dass nicht nur bei Glasfaser, sondern auch bei Satelliten äh der BND Selektoren von der NSA kriegt,
und eben nach bestimmten Handynummern, E-Mail-Adressen und so weiter in den Datenströmen filtert raussucht und die dann an die NSA gibt. Jetzt klang das in der Süddeutschen so, die äh äh NSA kriegt alles, was G zehn gefiltert ist.
Und äh das hat einige Bälle gemacht äh in der Öffentlichkeit, aber natürlich auch in diesem Ausschuss und dann gibt es jede Woche äh,
meist vor dem Ausschuss Pressegespräche von den einzelnen Fraktionen, von den Obleuten der Fraktionen äh in dem Ausschuss.
Und letzte Woche ja war natürlich das Thema und da hat der Obmann der SPD in dem Ausschuss das ist der Christian,
ähm eben den versammelten Journalisten gesagt, ja das ist nicht,
weil der BND, also das wurde nicht eingestellt, weil dem BND das rechtlich zu heikel war und weil der Filter nicht funktioniert hat, sondern weil der Filter so,
dass die NSA nur so wenige Daten erhalten hat, dass sie die ohnehin schon hatten und dass das äh ja unbrauchbar für die Wahl oder so.
Auch schenken konnten.
So war die Story dann von Christian Flieseck nichts Genaues, weiß man nicht. Ich war da auch nicht in der Sitzung dabei, weil normalerweise sind diese Pressefeld eine ziemlich langweilig, habe mir das ein, zwei Mal angeguckt, aber da kam nicht wirklich was Neues rum, deswegen,
auch noch andere Sachen zu tun, äh habe ich mir das nicht weitergegeben. Aber äh der Kollege von Golem,
hat sich da reingesetzt und dieses Statement von dem veröffentlicht, das wurde dann auch gleich auf Zeit online gecrosset und das ging dann auch so ein bisschen rum.
Und auf einmal hatten wir irgendwie die Situation, dass nicht irgendjemand aus der Geheimschutzstelle oder die Süddeutsche mit irgendwelchen Quellen, das Rechercheteam,
berichtet, sondern auch äh in Abgeordneter aus dem Ausschuss, der in diese Geheimschutzstelle gehen,
und diese Dokumente lesen darf ähm der Presse neue Sachen darüber erzählt hat.
Und das war wohl 'ne ganz schöne Rummel, denn wie gesagt zwar verdanken wir diesen ganzen Ausschüssen, die ganzen Erkenntnisse einem berühmten Liga,
aber das ist ja alles streng geheim und Licken ist verboten und genauso wie Rasen betreten, deswegen äh sollte er das lieber nicht machen.
Und denkst du, dass der Herr da Konsequenzen zu befürchten hat.
Soweit ich höre hat der tatsächlich gesagt bekommen du du du so nicht.
Ich war jetzt aber bei den Sitzungen nicht mit dabei, äh aber das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, was dann jetzt daraus folgt,
das weiß ich auch nicht so genau aber natürlich ist haben die Dienste selber kein Interesse dass das veröffentlicht wird und wahrscheinlich gibt's auch ein Gesetz das sagt streng geheime Sachen an die Presse geben ist nur so halb legal.
Gut.
Gab's auch eine neue Meldung aus dem Hause diese Publikationen, wo Greenboys,
Ist da auch glaube ich auch mit dabei, ne? Genau. Also quasi die ganzen.
Snowden-Dokument ohne ähm sich zusammengetan haben, nachdem ja früher vor allem Grünwald somit äh Guardian zusammengearbeitet hat.
Und da erscheinen ja dann immer mal wieder neue ähm.
Neue Artikel in dem Moment, wo eben wirklich neues Material aus dem Snowden, Archiv aufgearbeitet wurde, was jetzt neu dazukam, unter dem Titel Core Secrets war quasi,
die Schilderungen, dass die NSE auch Sabotage nicht scheut und ähm ordentlich ähm Aufwand betreibt.
Um sich Zugang zu Netzen zu beschaffen. Das Ganze war noch ein bisschen eingebettet in die Information, dass es auch nochmal so eine,
mindestens eine zusätzliche Geheimhaltungsstufe über topsecret äh zu geben scheint mit dem schönen äh Begriff exceptionaly compartmented Information, also das ist wirklich.
ECI. Ja, also so geheim war gestern, ja, also äh heute sind äh heute ist Information außer äh ordentlich äh tja, wie setzt man denn das jetzt am besten?
Geschottet, ja? Und ähm.
Im Rahmen dieser ganzen ECI-Geheimhaltungsstufen sind also jetzt im Rahmen der der der Veröffentlichung der Dokumente wiederum,
ja Sachen auch,
wieder hervorgekommen, die auch teilweise schon berichtet wurden teilweise vermutet wurden, dass nämlich die NSL ganz erheblich da unterwegs ist,
Mit Firmen zusammenzuarbeiten, um deren,
Krypto zu schwächen, ja, das ist so Stichwort Key Scrow, beziehungsweise ähm die etwas verborgene Variante, sprich nicht eine offizielle Hinterlegung eines Teilschlüssels, was ja ist, sondern,
ähm
das Belassen von Informationsschwächen oder das Einbringen von Informationsschwächen oder von Algorithmus äh Schwächen zum Beispiel indem man Zufall Zahlen, Generatoren nimmt, die eben nicht so zufällig sind, äh wie man's haben will. Sowas wird immer wieder vermutet in Chips.
Beziehungsweise eben auch, was den Algorithmus selber betrifft, dass einfach äh Hashing Algorithmen genommen werden, bei denen die NSA schon diese Information hat, dass dort
äh Schwächen vorliegen. Es gab ja ein entsprechende Vermutung einer ähnlichen Zusammenarbeit mit RSA. Das ist.
Weiß nicht ganz genau, so richtig belegt.
Das hat das ist nicht widersprochen, das hat Reuters letztes Jahr gebracht und die haben da auch 'ne Summe von zehn Millionen Dollar oder so an die Summe erinnere ich mich noch nicht ganz genau.
Also RSA hat dem Widerspruch, ne? Es gab ja dann auch.
Ja, äh die Firmen widersprechen dem immer alle, aber die NSA hat in äh nicht wieder äh widersprochen,
es gab ja dann auch in der äh Community, ist glaube ich die das Major-Concent, also es gab ja dann auch diese,
von RSR, RSA Security, wo sich eben einige Leute geweigert haben, äh da mitzumachen, dahin zu gehen, eben Bayreuthers ein paar Wochen vorher diese Story gebracht hat und weil das sehr plausibel ist, wie alles von den Snowden-Dokumenten, was wir bisher wissen,
wie so ziemlich nichts von dem offiziell widersprochen wurde. Da heißt's ja nur, aber wenn das falsch gewesen wäre, hätten die sofort äh,
Klagen und sowas, so ein Verleumdung, Falschdarstellung äh dran. Also auch die Reuterstory,
außer von ja natürlich weiß ich von nichts, aber das ist ja auch ein Problem, denn wenn sie was wissen, dann dürfen sie ja auch nichts sagen, das sehen wir auch beim Ausschuss, wenn dann der Leiter vom äh Dezix kommt, dann ist der,
vom deutschen Gesetz verpflichtet unter Eid dem Ausschuss die Wahrheit in die vollständige Wahrheit zu sagen aber in der Kooperation mit dem ist er verpflichtet niemals nur irgendjemand auch nur einzudeuten dass es sowas gibt. Das wird noch eine spannende rechtliche Frage
Genauso wird es die Domentis von Reuters sehen. Natürlich können die Öffentlichen nicht sagen, naja, Entschuldigung, äh im Übrigen ist unsere Aktie könnt ihr gleich in den Keller schießen.
Also ja, es ist bekannt, äh dass die NSA auf verschiedenen Stufen ähm Krypto sabotiert,
schon in in der Konzeptionsphase, dann in der in der Internet-Engineering Testforce und so,
äh an den Algorithmen äh in den Standards, dann aber auch in der Implementierung,
Wir hatten letztes Jahr äh einige Stories, äh das war auch von Glen und auch im äh Guardian.
Ähm dass äh sie ja Firmen infiltrieren,
um dort schwächere Standards einzusetzen, teilweise mit offizieller Kooperation, teilweise wissen die Firmen auch gar nichts davon,
die schicken dann einfach NSA Mitarbeiter als normaler Mitarbeiter in die Firmen das ist dann auch gut, damit der der Cheffirmenchef sagen kann ich weiß von nichts.
Ähm aber das war und eine so äh eine krasse Story war auch noch das Abfangen von Paketen,
Wenn man sich im Onlineshop eine Hardware klickt aber auf den Selektor in der Liste hat, dann blinkt irgendwo eine Lampe und dann kommt das Paket
ein zu einem besonderen Paketstation und da wird dann noch ein kleiner Chip eingebaut oder ausgebaut je nachdem und dann kommt's zu dir. Aber bisher,
war so die Story, dass das auf US-Boden mit US-Firmen passiert,
und jetzt die neue Story von den Kurs Secrets ist eben, dass das auch weltweit passiert,
unter anderem, da wurden drei äh Staaten namentlich genannt China, Südkorea, aber eben auch Deutschland.
Also die NSA ähm arbeitet auch mit äh was heißt, arbeiten mit deutschen Firmen zusammen, infiltriert äh deutsche Firmen, hat auch äh wahrscheinlich so eine Paket,
Abfangstationen in Deutschland,
und das ist jetzt die News aus diesen, diese Geheimatstufe kannte ich auch nicht, so nach VSNF DE und topsecret und darf nur der Präsident wissen, gibt's dann eben auch noch
exception League,
apartmented Information. Äh darauf haben sie ein bisschen gewartet, bis jetzt äh der Film von Laura rauskommt, weil in diesem Zusammenhang äh da wird das, soweit ich weiß, auch drin genannt.
Genau, da gibt's ja jetzt auch wieder so eine ganze Reihe von neuen äh Abkürzungen, die man da äh lernen darf, unter anderem Tarex, äh Target, Exploitation, das betrifft wohl im Wesentlichen diese Hardware äh Attacken
ähm geben jetzt auch in Südkorea, Deutschland eben China äh hier nachgewiesen wurden oder dokumentiert wurden.
Ja, das äh ich weiß gar nicht, was man dazu überhaupt noch alles noch äh sagen soll, ja.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen.
Es ist wirklich.
Es ist normal geworden, oder? Ja, das ist so eine News, vor zwei Jahren und das ganze Internet hätte sich zwei Wochen lang aufgeregt,
Nach einem anderthalben Jahr Snowden News ist das so wie wieder den Baustein. Ja, haben wir es doch alles schon immer gewusst. Krass, oder?
Ist normal, dass die komplette digitale Welt von den Diensten sabotiert wird.
Ja, es ist,
ja, es ist wirklich echt, echt krass, ja. Äh, vor allem, wenn man sich mal so vorstellt, es würde jetzt jemand mal, das wird hoffentlich auch hoffentlich auch bald mal passieren, ne, aber irgendwann.
Keine Ahnung, irgendwann sind ja dann vielleicht dieses Dokumente auch mal abgearbeitet, wenn wir sie hängen jetzt schon seit über einem Jahr an diesem Tropf und äh es kommt immer noch wieder was Neues raus und äh es fügt sich halt immer mehr zu einem Bild. Was ich in gewisser Hinsicht auch, also ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt
vorgehalten wird. Das ist einfach sehr viel Material,
überhaupt erstmal aufgearbeitet werden muss, gelesen werden muss, verstanden in Bezug gesetzt werden muss et cetera. Ich finde es insofern schon sehr bemerkenswert, wie dort
äh gearbeitet wird von diesem Kernteam und anderen ähm Beteiligten, Journalisten, dass sie es überhaupt geschafft haben, dass so.
Aufeinander aufbauend auch in gewisser Hinsicht äh zu präsentieren, wäre das alles auf einmal irgendwie gekommen, was er unmöglich
überhaupt zu fassen gewesen wäre, ähm wäre, glaube ich, die Wirkung auch nicht so nachhaltig. Und es macht so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, als ob wir noch in einem Jahr hier sitzen und es kommen nochmal neue Erkenntnisse, äh weil einfach so viel passiert, ja. Es ist ähm wirklich ähm.
Krass und äh finde es auch immer wieder erstaunlich.
Wie solche Behörden dann auch in so kurzen Zeiträumen, weil wir reden ja hier wirklich auch jetzt im Prinzip von Sachen, die,
nicht sehr viel älter als zwei, drei Jahre sind und die aber auch alle irgendwie erst in diesem Jahrtausend so richtig begonnen haben. Also so einen Zeitraum von zehn,
zehn Jahren eigentlich so 'ne Dekade was so 'ne Organisation oder die ganzen Geheimdienste an sich überhaupt,
Alles so unternehmen und in Bewegung setzen und miteinander in Korrelation setzen, wo man schon fast nicht die Möglichkeit hat, das überhaupt zu verstehen, wenn man's erzählt bekommt, geschweige denn sich zu stellen, was es überhaupt für eine logistische.
Organisatorische Aktion ist, das alles überhaupt erst mal loszutreten, beziehungsweise überhaupt auch diese kriminelle Dynamik äh äh zu zu entwickeln, das auch alles zu betreiben, ja. Also
ähm
Irgendwann wird's dann vielleicht mal so einen schönen Film geben, der dann äh mit tollen drei D Animationen uns äh all diese ganzen Abkürzungen und Aktivitäten in Zusammenhang bringt und dann äh,
wird das bestimmt ein ganz spannender Kinoabend. Ob das dann in irgendeiner Form von der Menschen und dem politischen System mehr verstanden wird, ähm,
Da habe ich mittlerweile so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, weil eigentlich jeder, der jetzt auch grade im deutschen politischen System unterwegs ist,
diese mit, na ja, die der Amerikaner machen da was und wir können ja nichts dagegen tun und wir müssen ja gut Freund sein, die es irgendwie die verblasst und er setzt sich zunehmenden Maße in so ein.
Five Eis hin, Five Eis her, äh
das westliche politische System hat sich im Prinzip schon zu so einer Art Gesamtgeheimdienst zusammengetan, der äh auch gedeckt wird von allen Regierungen
wer auch immer an eine Regierung kommt,
Ja, äh da fällt mir immer wieder dieses gleiche äh Zitat ein hier von dem ähm amerikanischen.
So peinlich, er ist ja auch schon gestorben. Ja, also dieses neuer Präsident wird gewählt, so und als erstes wird er in so einen Raum
geführt, wo eben dieser Film gezeigt wird. So, hier aus einem anderen Winkel, den man bisher noch nicht kannte und wenn der Film zu Ende ist,
Eddy Questions und ich glaube,
So eine ähnliche Prozedur dürfte es hier in Deutschland auch geben, aber hier irgendwie erst mal Bundeskanzler äh wird oder auch nur so halbwegs in irgend hinter irgendeine Tür geführt wird, die mehr als zehn Zentimeter dick ist, dann kriegt man auch irgendwie so einen Film gezeigt und ich weiß gar nicht, ob man
ob man den überhaupt sehen will.
Ja tatsächlich äh die Obama war ja auch die große Hoffnung aller Bürgerrechtler,
und wir sehen, dass er in bestimmten Bereichen sogar noch viel schlimmere Sachen macht, als sein äh Vorgänger
äh und auch die äh deutsche Aufrüstung des BND und Zusammenarbeit mit dem äh mit der NSA äh wurde von Rot-Grün gemacht.
Nach es gibt da so ein Geheimnis mit dem was der BND Präsident damals mit der NSA unterzeichnet hat und das ist die juristische Basis dieser extrem engen Kooperation. Das geht alles auf äh Schröders Kanzlerschaft zurück.
Hm.
Einen Film auf jeden Fall äh gibt es jetzt schon, auch wenn wir ihn noch nicht gesehen haben, aber andere Leute haben das schon getan und zwar aus dem selben Hause, über das wir hier schon die ganze Zeit sprechen von
ein ja Dokumentationsfilm über Snowden und die erste Zeit ähm danach,
Citizen vor, heißt der Film,
benannt nach dem Nickname, dem sich Snowden selbst gegeben hat, als er äh das erste Mal kontaktiert hat. Das waren so die ersten verschlüsselten E-Mails. So fängt auch ein Trailer an, den man sich äh derzeit anschauen kann, wo dann erstmal so.
Commander ein und,
PGP, hm so richtiger Nerdpoint eigentlich, ne? Schon interessant, wo wir äh gelandet sind. Ja und ähm dieser Film wurde jetzt bisher in den USA gezeigt.
Was hast du verstanden, wie der das Release jetzt aussehen soll? Wie lange wollen Sie da warten?
Das kommt jetzt also ähm letzten Freitag war Premiere auf einem Filmfestival in New York City
auch anwesend war und äh ein paar andere Kumpels aus New York und ja demnächst
äh ich glaube, kann's nicht sogar sein, dass der vierzehnte irgendwie war oder so oder der vierundzwanzigste. Also noch in diesem Monat äh geht das los natürlich erstmal mit,
Kino, aber es steht zu erwarten, wie das so ist in diesem Internet, dass vor allem bei,
die an Netzthemen sind, dass der dann auch früher oder später auf der Piratenbucht des Vertrauens auftaucht.
Okay, hier habe ich die Information. Am sechsten November in deutsche Kinos.
Ja, aber die Frage ist halt nicht, wann er in deutsche Kinos kommt, sondern auf deutsche IP-Adressen und äh na gut, aber das wird sich dann halt von alleine lösen. Hoffen wir, denken wir, wissen wir.
Ja, äh ich bin gespannt. Äh Laura hat ja vorher auch schon zwei äh Filme gemacht in dieser Reihe. Äh my Country, my Country, über ähm
den US-Krieg im Irak äh und le Off äh über Muslime in den Staaten und Guantanamo. Und das ist der Dritte in der Reihe,
und den hatte sie schon angefangen der Weltöffentlichkeit aufgetaucht ist ja,
habe äh mal kennengelernt und so ein paar Leute, die mit dem Film zu tun haben. Ich bin sehr gespannt äh und erste Leute äh die die Premiere in New York gesehen haben, haben gemeint, ist sehr bewegend. Äh dann sollte man sich unbedingt anschauen.
Trailer auch dann so Berlin.
Wieder porträtiert wird, aber das Berlin ist ja eh das neue für die oder so.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist es äh so der die Versteckhöhle für alle Animal Number Ones, die wir derzeit so in USA ausmachen können, ne. Ja, ob das so gut ist, weiß ich auch nicht, aber so ist es nun mal, ne.
Ja, ähm kommen wir zu ähm.
Und zwar zunächst einmal Termin, die wir verschlafen haben. Letztes Mal hatten wir hier nichts anzukündigen, hätten wir aber äh eigentlich gehabt, haben wir aber verpennt, hat uns drauf keiner hingewiesen, dass für dich aber jetzt niemandem die Schuld zu schieben, selber äh,
es gab eine Demo und zwar gegen TTIP, das geplante Freihandelsabkommen zwischen,
Der EU und den USA, nicht nur den EU und USA, sondern im Prinzip gibt es ja eine ganze Reihe solcher
Abkommen, die geplant sind. Hier zeichnet sich im Prinzip so eine neue, globale wirtschaftliche Vernetzung ab, das heißt ähnliche Verhandlungen laufen auch mit Japan, mit Kanada
in vielen anderen Ländern. Und ja, der Streit ist ja hier ganz klar der äh um die Art und Weise, ähm wie,
dort verhandelt wird und natürlich auch worüber verhandelt wird, auch wenn man eben nicht genau weiß warum, weil es wird dem geheim verhandelt. Es gab jetzt eine Demo gegen TTIP in ja angeblich über tausend Städten. Ich habe mich nachgezählt, aber offensichtlich
schon einiges in Bewegung gesetzt, in Deutschland auch. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo warten? Hast du das irgendwie mitbekommen?
Auch noch in der Tagesschau gesehen.
Also wir sind.
Verschiedenen Städten, glaube ich.
Genau, wir sind unterinformiert und äh prallen das an. Also wenn ihr von solchen Sachen ähm Bescheid wisst, könnt ihr das hier gerne ähm,
stecken, dann können wir das vielleicht auch mal vorher ankündigen. Aber man kriegt ja nicht alles mit. Ja, diese ganze TTIP-Nummer müssen wir hier,
schon auch nochmal aufgreifen, da suchen wir noch nach den richtigen Gesprächspartnern. So oder so, es gibt da einen interessanten,
Artikel, auf den man vielleicht nochmal verweisen kann auf Zeit Online von Sven Gigold, von den Grünen, der diesem ganzen TTIP-Ding ähm,
sehr aktiv ist, der auch äh zu der Gruppe gehörte, die ähm dieses Verhandlungsmandat der EU,
für die TTIP-Verhandlungen mit der USA vor dem Jahr schon äh geliebt hat und da tätig EU.
Das Dokument soll ja jetzt im Prinzip auch,
öffentlich gemacht werden, was ganz lustig ist, ja, es ist irgendwie schon öffentlich und jetzt ähm preist sich quasi die EU mit dieser äh Transparenzinitiative nur
Ein Verhandlungsmandat ist halt das eine, das ist nicht mehr als ein Notizball
wo drauf steht, na ja, wir könnten ja mal darüber reden und das sind so erstmal jetzt in der ersten Verhandlungsstufe das, was wir als akzeptabel ansehen et cetera, das gibt schon mal einen Einblick. Aber die eigentlichen Verhandlungen selber sind halt nach wie vor
geschlossenen Türen. Der Zugang von
ähm Nonnen-NGO äh Lobbygruppen, sprich Unternehmensverbände, et cetera oder auch Einzelunternehmen scheint sehr groß zu sein. Da wurde man nachgezählt. Man kam so auf zweiundneunzig Prozent aller Lobbytreffen drehen sich eben,
solchen Organisationen und was ich auch noch nicht so verinnerlicht hatte, das ist wohl auch,
Ein ganz interessanten Dokumentenschwarzmarkt zu geben scheint im europäischen Parlamentsumfeld, wo also mit.
Richtigen Menge Geld, auch Dokumente mal beschafft werden können, ja, Leaks sind ja dann meistens kostenlos, aber hier gibt's offensichtlich auch eine,
gute Zweitverdienst ähm Strecke für manche Mitarbeiter, Parlamentarier weiß man nicht, wer das dann letzten Endes
das ist natürlich auch keine schöne Sache, zumal ja, jetzt gibt's ja gerade auf EU-Ebene auch so dieses ganze
gebt doch mal eure Zweiteinkommen an und so, wo ähnlich wie auch im Bundestag da sehr fishi Kategorien gemacht werden, uns nicht wirklich klar ist, äh ist wohl nur eine Minderheit, die wirklich sehr gut verdient, die dann aber sehr wohl.
Ob der Rest genug Geld hat, um das Leben zu bestreiten und dann auf diesen Schwarzmarkt ausweichen muss, wissen wir nicht,
Aber so was wird hier berichtet von einem halbwegs Insider. Ja und ähm
Was ja auch noch interessant äh beschrieben hat, dass ja äh sowohl im EU-Parlamentarier teilweise eben Zugänge haben,
Auch diese Dokumente einzusehen, dass es da wieder so eine ähnliche Situation hier wie beim Untersuchungsausschuss, ja, da gibt's dann so einen Leseraum, da muss man dann irgendwie Stifte und Mobiltelefonen, Kameras, et cetera alles draußen lassen, das heißt, man muss das so alles äh im,
speichern. Ähm
Und die Regelungen sind wohl für EU-Parlamentarier noch ein bisschen härter als sie für Mitglieder des Bundestags gelten,
Fand ich eine ganz interessante Information. Ich kann jetzt nicht genau wiedergeben, worin dieser Unterschied besteht, aber es äh teilweise weniger restriktiv, was den Zugang zu Dokumenten betrifft. Also da ist auf jeden Fall noch eine ganze Menge
mehr möglich auf EU-Parlamentsebene dort den Parlamentsmitgliedern mehr Einblick zu geben und das wäre natürlich.
Ja, das ist schon äh vom Prozess her äh ziemlich kritikwürdig, der wenn äh einerseits mit den USA bei Hittipp, aber auch mit Kanada bei et cetera.
Riesige Abkommen verhandelt, die Auswirkungen auf alle Einwohner dieser Regionen und wahrscheinlich auch noch den Rest der Weltwirtschaft haben,
und,
Verhandlungen sind geheim teilweise wird noch nicht mal bekannt gegeben, wer denn jetzt äh in welcher Position geschweige denn den Namen für die EU dort am Verhandlungstisch sitzt und wo die Verhandlungsrunden sind.
Ähm es gibt aber manche Lobbyisten, die bei diesem Verhandlungs äh Runden mit drin sitzen dürfen, im Gegensatz zur Öffentlichkeit und im Gegensatz zu manchen gewählten Abgeordneten. Das ist total skurril.
Gehen Verhandlungen über Jahre,
und äh Abgeordnete und die Öffentlichkeit versuchen Fragen natürlich permanent nach, dürfen wir auch mal was erfahren, dürfen wir auch mal was erfahren. Ab und zu gibt's mal so einen kleinen und so,
aber erst in den letzten Monaten, also bei TTIP, das wird ja noch verhandelt, aber bei CETA das so ein bisschen als Blaupause für TTIP gilt, haben wir das jetzt schon gesehen. Ähm.
Die Abgeordneten wissen bis zum Schluss nicht offiziell, was denn da drin steht.
Nur so grobe Linien, die dann die Kernfragen auch in der Öffentlichkeit debattiert werden und die von der Kommission äh dann auch an die Öffentlichkeit äh bekanntgegeben werden.
Aber erst äh als die Verhandlungen so ziemlich fertig waren, äh und an die Mitgliedsstaaten auch geschickt wurden, weil die hatten das ja vorher auch noch nicht. Ähm
ach, ich habe,
IFG-Anfragen gestellt und so geht es um eine ganz aktuelle äh das aktuelle TTIP. Und da hieß es immer, erst hieß es, haben wir nicht, äh haben uns noch nicht zugeschickt oder ist noch nicht fertig, deswegen können wir dir das noch nicht schicken
ähm dann irgendwann wurde es verschickt, ne, dann hat die Tagesschau so den Grund äh Vertrag äh gelegt.
Fünfhundert Seiten, der eigentliche Vertrag von tausendsechshundert Seiten,
haben wir gefragt, so jetzt ist es aber verschickt, jetzt wollen wir jetzt wollen wir das aber auch mal haben, dann hatten wir das Wirtschaftsministerium gesagt, Yannick ist zwar fertig und liegt uns vor, aber können wir den nicht geben, weil das würde die internationalen Beziehungen zu Kanada äh beeinträchtigen.
Da habe ich gesagt, okay, dann probiere ich's halt bei der EU, habe Torten-IFG-Antrag gestellt und die haben dann gemeint, ja, wart mal!
Ein paar Tage die Anhörung von Simpsilia als neue Handelskommissarin in Brüssel war, haben die das selber auf ihrer Webseite,
gestellt. Das war so ein bisschen skurril. Wir hatten das geleakt aber wirklich,
das ist vom Journal, vom Zugang her eine Frechheit was so passiert, dass da Abkommen geheime Runde ausgeklüngelt werden, Lobbyisten sind aber dabei und dann, wenn ein Text fertig ist, heißt ja, jetzt können wir den aber nicht mehr ändern
weil dann müssen wir den ganzen Prozess so neu aufholen und das geht nicht. Wir haben uns jetzt endlich mal geeinigt. Ihr könnt jetzt nur noch frisst oder stirb zusagen oder ablehnen. Skurril.
Na ja, es ist.
Mal ganz abgesehen von dem, was dann da drin steht ähm,
Die, grade die großen Fragen von diesem äh Investorenklagerecht, das hast du ja auch in anderen Podcasts äh ab und zu mal angesprochen und das ist ja das, was dann auch in der Tagesschau.
Besprochen würde, aber auch aus Netzpolitischer Perspektive sind dann so Fragen wird damit Datenschutz ausgehöhlt, kommen dann mit so Regelungen oder DRM durch die Hintertür wieder rein, dass das alles noch ziemlich fischy.
Auf jeden Fall scheint mir diese ganze TTIP Sache so ein bisschen die ähm so Potenzial zu haben, so ähnlich wie Acta einzuschlagen, weil das einfach insbesondere diese kleine,
Ausarbeitung, also vollkommen unabhängig auch von dem, was da eigentlich behandelt wird, denke ich mal, gibt's schon so eine.
Relativ großes Verständnis in der Bevölkerung, dass das so eine kleine Ausarbeitung einfach,
Geht. Also das das ist schon äh etwas, was was vermittelbar zu sein scheint. Inwiefern das jetzt noch weiter ähm Raum greift, das müssen wir abwarten.
Zuspruch bei der Demo war jetzt so schlecht wohl nicht. Ich habe jetzt hier keine belastbaren Zahlen, deswegen werde ich jetzt auch keine nennen. Und ich hoffe, dass wir die nächsten äh Terminansage da auch nicht äh verkacken.
Eine Zahl habe ich aber noch. Wenn ich da Medienberichterstattung äh wenn ich das richtig aufgeschnappt habe, als das vorbeiscrollte. Äh es gab wohl irgendwie auch wieder normale Unterschriftensammlung, eine Petition gegen TTIP,
da sind wohl schon eine Viertelmillionen Unterschriften gegen TTIP wieder gesammelt worden.
Aber es gab ja auch schon mal eine europäische Bürgerinitiative, die das Quorum von einer Million Stimmen äh erreicht hat gegen TTIP
und als es fertig war die zweite erfolgreiche europäische Bürgerinitiative nach dem Recht auf Wasser und als die erfolgreich war, hat dann die Kommission gesagt, ja
Ist ja nett, dass ihr das fordert, aber geht nicht, weil geht nicht.
Sorry.
Auch klagen und so. Aber tatsächlich, das sind mindestens eine Millionen Menschen, die dagegen unterschrieben haben äh und da ist Potential da, da weiterhin politisch aktiv zu sein.
Das denke ich auch. Äh ja, Talking About Potential für politische Aktivität. Ähm.
Müssen wir noch von der anderen Veranstaltung berichten, die ist nämlich jetzt nicht mehr äh geben wird. Äh Freiheit statt Argent, die jährliche Demo aus der in Anführungsstrichen Netzgemeinde heraus organisiert
ich hatte das hier mit Linus auch schon etwas ausführlicher äh besprochen in Lokbuchnetzpolitik hundertvierzehn. Nachdem die letzte stattgefunden hat und wo wir auch beide nicht da waren und wo wir auch beide ausführlich mal miteinander gesprochen haben, warum
wir dann nicht da waren und warum wir auch so die Zukunft dieses äh Events ein wenig ja skeptisch.
Gesehen haben. Jetzt gab's einen Beschluss, dass die Freiheit Angst auch nicht mehr stattfinden wird. Und dass das jetzt quasi die letzte Veranstaltung in dieser Form unter diesem Namen war.
Da genaueres.
Genau. Es gab äh ein Nachbereitungstreffen vom Demobündnis.
Jetzt muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen und so, ein bisschen politisch ausgleichend, sprechen, denn ich habe mir da durchaus auch eine Meinung, die auch auf dem Treffen vertreten, aber was da ungefähr rauskam, ist, ähm.
Alle waren sich einig, dass dieser Name äh überhaupt nicht tauglich ist, äh um Leute zu ziehen.
Also der Name wird sowieso äh einkassiert und dann aber auch,
Ritual, jährliche Großdemonstration, weil schon wieder Spätsommer ist, weil wir es schon immer so gemacht haben. Das soll es so auch nicht mehr geben.
Tatsächlich in den ersten Jahren und
die Organisation vom Krieg, äh da so zwotausendsieben, acht, neun und so, da war da wirklich Power drin, da ist da jedes Mal ist das jedes Jahr größer geworden und so von hundert Hanseln äh dann irgendwo steht auf der Webseite bis zu hunderttausend,
auf jeden Fall ist das immer größer geworden und wir hatten wir hatten konkrete Themen war die Verabschiedung des Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetzes kurz vor uns,
und dann die Klage gegen die Vorratszeitensprechung und dann war diese ganze Zensursula im Moment und so. Das Ding ist explodiert und die Demo stand auch irgendwie für das ist die Netzgemeinde, die ist jetzt auf der Straße, weg vom Bildschirm. Hallo, wir sind sichtbar,
aber seitdem ähm gab's diesen Kern, Aufreger, diese mobilisierende ähm brennende Thema,
zudem es auch einen politischen Entscheidungsprozess gibt, den man damit konkret beeinflussen kann,
nicht. Und es wurde irgendwie so ein bisschen dazu übergegangen, ja, es ist halt schon wieder ein Jahr rum, machen wir wieder eine Demo, weil war so immer. Äh dann kommt aber so eine Berichterstattung raus, wie jetzt bei Spiegel Online Stand. Ja, das ist halt nur so ein Treffen der Szene.
Ähm und da kommen jetzt nur noch viertausend Leute, statt äh irgendwie, was auch immer für ja große Zahlen da vorher mal waren. Also.
Es ist nach außen unattraktiv äh und es verschlimmt wahnsinnig viele Ressourcen,
ähm auf den Treffen ist gefallen, dass so pro Demonstrant so ungefähr zehn Euro ausgegeben wurden, das ist hanebüchen, äh die Netzgemeinde hat kein Geld. Äh wir sind machen das alle ehrenamtlich.
Großen Teil wir müssen mit unseren Ressourcen,
Haushalten und es gibt viele viele kleine punktuelle Themen bezogene Aktionen und es gab die Idee mehr auf sowas zu achten und nicht jetzt,
ja auch hat der Vergleich gefallen, schon mal wieder Spätsommer ist was zu machen, was bringt einen Castor Protest in drei Wochen nachdem der Zug durchgefahren ist.
Ähm man sollte dann die bei der digitalen Agenda oder bei einem BND Haushaltserhöhung oder bei einer Ausschusssitzung oder wenn's was Konkretes gibt, kleine, feine Aktionen machen und nicht äh in diese Routine,
verfallen und das war mit großen Stimmen war 'ne sehr große Mehrheit dafür auf dem Bündnis treffen,
die Namen Freiheit statt Angst nicht weiter für Aktionen zu nutzen und diese ritualisierte große Bündnisdemo abzuschaffen, zumal gerade in den letzten Jahren die ja eh nicht mehr für die Netzgemeinde,
spricht, was aber tatsächlich ein Problem ist, nach außen äh politische Entscheidungsträger,
Die haben tatsächlich in den letzten Jahren verlautbar lassen, guck mal, die kriegt ja noch nicht mal, das ist die Netzgemeinde, jetzt kommen hier so ein paar tausend Hanseln und werden von irgendeiner Fahrraddemo in äh den Medien äh ausgepowert,
die mehr Leute zieht, ne da da ist diese Demo nicht nur nicht hilfreich genug, sondern da schadet sie dem gemeinsamen Anliegen ganz konkret,
zusammen mit der Ressourcenverschwendung hat dazu geführt, dass viele Leute ähm.
Ja, hat sich dafür ausgesprochen haben, das Ding ist äh nicht mehr so zu machen. Natürlich gibt's ja jetzt die übliche Mailinglisten-Diskussion danach, äh wie das äh beinahe unausweichlich ist. Aber es gab auch gleich äh andere Vorschläge, eben,
Protest in andere Rahmen zu lenken. Ich meine,
es gibt ja nicht nur die Aktionsform Straßenprotest, äh es passiert ja durchaus äh einiges. Also manche Leute haben das mit dem Konzept der politischen Partei probiert
äh andere sind in NGOs und machen Lobbyarbeit, wieder anderem, klagen irgendwie CCC in Konstanze kurz, die haben so, keine Ahnung, eine Hand vollklagen, äh mindestens äh gegen die Geheimdienstüberwachung.
Für die vielfältigsten äh Aktions- und Protestformen,
und ein was neues hat auch das gleich vorgeschlagen dieses
Latsch Demo mit Bratwurst Ding hinter uns zu lassen und irgendeinen äh gemeinsames Lied von der Bühne aus zu singen, sondern wie wär's äh ganz konkret? Ähm ist,
Wir leben in der Vollüberwachung und vor fünfundzwanzig Jahren äh wurde in einem Unrechtsstaat äh die Geheimdienstzentralen gestürmt,
Wie wär's äh so was mal auszuprobieren mit zivilen Ungehorsam zu leisten, ähnlich wie es auch äh Blockaden von Nazi Demos, Blockaden von Castro-Transporten gibt,
so eine Aktionsformen zum Beispiel warum nicht einfach mal die BMD-Zentrale stürmen, mal auszuprobieren, mal als Vorschlag in die Runde geworfen,
Ich fand das ganz spannend das haben wir jetzt genug Zeit
darüber nachzudenken, die und die Ressourcen nicht wieder an dieses Ritualdings da zu binden von Geld und Personalien, sondern uns zu überlegen, was wollen wir politisch, wie können wir das am besten erreichen? Welche Ressourcen haben wir dafür? Lasst uns das angehen.
Ja, also bei mir rennt sie damit äh ohnehin offene Türen ein. Das ist so im Wesentlichen eigentlich genau das, was wir schon äh vor ein paar Wochen hier so diskutiert haben und auch ich bin ein großer Freund. Ähm vielleicht an dieser Stelle mal für,
Inspirierte Menschen. Ähm ich habe mal einen Podcast gemacht im Rahmen von die Gesellschafter, schon ein bisschen her, aber äh nach wie vor aktuell, wie ich finde, mit ähm einem Vertreter von Camp-Act.
Muss gleich nochmal nachschlagen
Wie der Gesprächspartner hieß Günther Metzges und äh das war sehr interessant, nicht? Weil also Camp-Act, wer das nicht kennt, ist ja so ein auch so ein links orientiertes äh Bündnis,
wo ähm per Mailliste im Wesentlichen immer wieder äh Leute aufgefordert werden. Ähm.
Mitzumachen bei spezifischen Aktionen, die sehr zielgerichtet sind und sehr punktiert sind. Einige Beispiele, was ich sehr ähm.
Was ich sehr überzeugend fand, war zum Beispiel der Einfluss, der auf ähm einzelne Bundestagsabgeordnete gemacht wurde. Ähm vor allem bei äh vor Wahlen,
Ja, also das war dann, glaube ich, konkret jetzt hier die die äh wie heißt nochmal? Ilse, Ilgner, äh,
Ilse Eigner, genau, die ja damals ähm auch zuständig war für.
Verbraucherschutz und die.
In ihrem eigenen Wahlkreis Veranstaltungen gemacht hat und dort sind dann die Leute irgendwie aufgeschlagen und haben einfach die.
Konkrete, die quasi auf ihrer eigenen Wahlkampfveranstaltung ähm,
auftauchte, verdickt mit Leuten, die einfach gesagt haben, hier hör mal,
Genverarbeitete äh Futtermittel et cetera. Wir sind äh dagegen. Und sowas hat natürlich eine ganz andere Wirkung. Weil erstmal, man erreicht unmittelbar die Leute, die entscheiden.
Ja, also ist nicht irgendwie eine abstrakte Truppe, die irgendwo in Mitte äh inmitten von Touristen im Kreis läuft, während die anderen sich in der Nase bohren oder am Wochenende sind.
Und Eichhörnchen im Tiergarten.
Und Eichhörnchen im Tiergarten, genau. Äh,
ja, es es sind dann im Idealfall halt auch genau die Politiker, die sich mit einem speziellen Themenfeld auch quasi befassen müssen oder eben als Sachpolitiker in diesem Bereich unterwegs sind,
und man hat auch eine eine unmittelbare Ansprache. Also man steht mit denen am selben,
und kann die Argumente äh mehrfach auch im Idealfall ja auch zivilisiert und geordnet und halbwegs sortiert äh rüberbringen. Das ist einfach in seiner ganzen Effizienz und vor allem auch
in seiner Kostenstruktur, ja? Ich meine, da muss man jetzt nicht zehn Euro pro Teilnehmer äh ausgeben, um das überhaupt zu ermöglichen. Das sind einfach alles so
ähm Ideen, die ich einfach für sehr äh angemessen halte, insbesondere in so einer wohlvernetzten
Struktur, in der wir uns einfach befinden. Ich meine, wenn wir irgendeinen Vorteil haben, jetzt politisch was,
zu bewegen, dann dass wir eben das Netz auch haben. Und das, denke ich mal, könnte man sich mal beherzigen. Ansonsten bin ich eigentlich am gespanntesten auf die Ideen, die bisher noch nicht geäußert wurden.
Hier gibt's einfach Potential.
Ja, wir hatten sowas auch schon äh in der Netzgemeinde, also die,
äh ehemalige Justizministerin Brigitte Zypries hat auf der Republika gesagt, in meinem Wahlkreis hat keiner Vertrauen verloren, weil die Geheimdienste uns alle überwachen und das
haben wir verblockt und das haben das Leute aus dem lokalen CCC gelesen und sind zu ihrer nächsten äh Sitzung im Wahlkreis hin und da war das unmittelbar Thema und so
sowas ist wirklich pointiert, zielgenau, man hat einen Adressat, man hat einen thematischen äh Aufhänger, äh und das ist auch mal was Neues äh als immer nur,
Runde zu drehen.
Genau.
Gut kommen wir zum äh Ende. Diesmal haben wir noch ein paar äh Termine, schöne Musik lassen wir jetzt mal weg. Äh das alles sehr äh kurzfristig hier äh am.
Sechzehnten zehnten morgen, genau, zum Zeit,
also wäre das hier immer alles äh quasi live, fast live hört, hat noch eine Gelegenheit dabei zu sein, eine Demo veranstaltet von der äh digitalen Gesellschaft in Berlin gegen Geheimdienste.
Da kann man also dann doch nochmal ein bisschen auf der Straße rumlatschen oder.
Ja ähm.
Also wer da wer das vermisst.
Naja, es,
es geht ja nicht nur um äh die äh Latstimmung äh des gemeinsamen Ablaufens, äh sondern man kann ja mit einer kleinen, feinen Demo durchaus pointiert auch
was wir morgen vorhaben ist den Überwachungsskandal, dass die BND elementar mit verstrickt ist,
in die Komplettüberwachung der Menschheit,
sichtbar zu machen und auch den Leuten, die politisch dafür verantwortlich sind, also eine kurze Demonstration geben, äh die natürlich auch sehr für Fotos äh geeignet ist, um dann in den Stock Archiven zu landen und bei dem nächsten Mal, wenn irgendwie,
Switch mit dem K5 Kabel äh fotografiert werden soll für die Überwachung. Äh man stattdessen mal äh coole Bilder hat, die man auch in die Medien nehmen können. Also wir werden den Adressat Bundeskanzleramt und wenn wir äh,
Wir starten große gebastelt, äh wir wollen hier vors Bundeskanzleramt stellen,
und dann aber auch vor Brandenburger Tor der US-Botschaft und dann aber auch den Entscheidungsträgern das direkt zeigen bis rüber zur Brücke vom ARD Hauptstadtstudio wo der BND.
Jetzt habe ich euch angenommen, wo der BND Untersuchungsausschuss,
äh Tag, nämlich aus dem Sitzungssaal wird man dann diese Abschlusskundgebung dieser kleinen aber feinen, nicht ressourcenverschlingenden Demo auch sehen können.
Quasi die Leute, die für die Aufklärung da sind, kriegen das unmittelbar zu Gesicht und nicht nur die Touris und Eichhörnchen im Tiergarten,
das wird morgen 'ne Demonstration sein, bisher ruft da die digitale Gesellschaft dazu auf ich glaube es ist noch nicht ganz spruchreif, aber ich glaube das werden nicht die einzigen bleiben, die aufrufen, das wird man dann heute in diesem Internet,
bekommen.
Okay, wir rufen auf jeden Fall auch auf.
Morgen früh um zehn Bundeskanzleramt.
Genau,
wer dann dabei gewesen ist, der darf dann auch Freitag äh stolz sein neues netzpolitischen Aktivismus äh feiern und zwar bei der zehn Jahre Party von Netzpolitik Punkt
org, wo du ja mitschreibst, wie ich schon erwähnte und wie das wahrscheinlich sowieso jeder weiß, ähm ja, vor zehn Jahren, also,
Jetzt wird gefeiert. Der eigentliche Zehnjahrestermin fiel glaube ich so aufn August oder so irgendwie so mitten mitten äh auf jeden
FA in den Ferien irgendwie, wo sowieso alle was besseres zu tun hatten. Also hat man sich äh vorgenommen, das Ganze dann zu einem besseren Zeitpunkt
durchzuziehen, das ist dann halt am Freitag und das Ganze wird so eine Tageskonferenz, ein, also eine Eintageskonferenz sein, wo verschiedene ähm
kluge Sachen sagen werden und am Abend gibt's auch noch eine Party. Aber.
Genau
Doman ist zehn Punkt Netzpolitik Punkt org und wenn dieser Podcast rechtzeitig erscheint und nicht erst in fünfhundert Jahren angehört wird, äh und ihr eine Mail schickt, dass ihr äh auch Netzcommunity, TM oder äh Aktivist oder wie auch immer seid, schickt mir eine Mail, dann könnt ihr noch auf die Freundschaftsliste für einen ermäßigten Eintritt.
Ja, also er wird nicht erst in fünfhundert Jahren veröffentlicht.
Aber gehört. Ähm aber vielleicht gibt's dann ja.
Ähm ja, das auf jeden Fall. Ja, ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Vielleicht gibt's dann Zeitmaschinen. Mindestens.
Mindestens fünfhundert Jahre, mindestens fünfhundert Jahre. Ja, so ist das mit Podcast, ja? Wir haben extrem hohe Halbwerkzeiten. Letzter Tipp ist die Pfiff. Con.
Steht Pfiff aus dem Kopf, Tim.
Forum, Informatiker, Freiheit.
Forum Informatikerinnen und Informatiker für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwort.
Ah ja. Okay.
Die veranstalten also auch ein altehrwürdig.
Ja, ich glaube, die sind ungefähr so alt wie der. Der hat's dann mal geschafft, sich umzubenennen, äh, Pfiff immer noch nicht.
Wie auch immer. Äh es wird veranstaltet und zwar wieder in Berlin, wie das so ist, in der TU Berlin, um genauer zu sein und das Ganze findet statt am siebten und achten November.
Welches ist ein Freitag und ein Samstag?
Dreißig Jahre Feier.
Genau. Das Ganze findet statt unter dem Titel der Fall des Geheimen, einen Blick unter den eigenen,
und ähm hier wird halt nochmal genauer analysiert, wie denn so der Kenntnisstand ist über die deutschen Geheimnisse, die Rolle Deutschlands im internationalen System, Echolon, Prison, Alconal, sprich so die letzten zehn, fünfzehn Jahre,
Überwachungshistorie und äh entsprechender Berichterstattung. Wer also
noch nicht ausreichend Überblick erhalten hat, könnte es unter Umständen dort.
Empfehlen wir der CCC auch.
Genau, ja, ist ja auch was von Krieger dabei, Konstanze Kurz dabei, Wolfgang Neskovic sei angefragt, Anne Roth
Herr angefragt, ob er kommen wird. Also der Vorsitzende des Untersuchungsausschusses, ich weiß nicht, der wird sich das bestimmt Andi Müller, also.
Viele äh.
Verdächtige und noch ein paar, die ich nicht äh kenne, ah Wolfgang Koi ist auch noch dabei. Also ja, eine sehr interessante ähm personelle Zusammenstellung und vielleicht seid ihr ja auch mit dabei mit dabei und macht die personelle Zusammenstellung,
doch interessanter. Womit wir am Ende dieser Ausgabe angekommen werden.
Internet ist alle.
Bedeutet es alle, du musst jetzt auch äh holt dich weiter Berichterstatten.
Ich muss auch noch ein bisschen arbeiten neben so einer Konferenz am Freitag, ja. Und morgen ist wieder Ausschusssitzung.
Auch noch. So so. Morgen ist schon wieder Ausschusssitzung.
Ja, könnt ihr alle hinkommen, müsst ihr euch nur heute euch noch anmelden, per Mail schreiben, morgen ist Ausschusssitzung vom Untersuchungsausschuss. Deswegen machen wir ja die Demo morgen, damit die Ausschussmitglieder das sehen.
Ah, okay, das heißt, man kann entweder bei der Demo teilnehmen oder im Ausschuss sitzen.
Man kann erst an der Demo teilnehmen und äh der Ausschuss wird eine nicht-öffentlichen Teil haben von elf bis zu ungefähr zwölf, der dann ähm aus dem man dann unsere Demo sehen kann und ab zwölf oder später geht der öffentliche Teil los. Man kann also unmittelbar anschließend dann reingehen.
Verstehe praktische Erwägungen, muss man ja durchaus hier nochmal anführen.
Geplant.
Hammer. Okay, na gut, dann ist ja sozusagen euer Nachmittag schon verplant. Ja, aber ansonsten haben wir jetzt eigentlich nichts mehr zu berichten, oder?
Nö, Internet ist alle. Bis Freitag zu unserer Party.
Genau und äh in diesem Sinne wünschen wir euch äh alles Gute und ich hoffe, ihr hattet wieder etwas Spaß bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschau, tschau.